bonsoir et bienvenue ça vous regarde en
direct notre grand témoin ce soir et
l'un des nouveaux visages de la lutte
pour le climat bonsoir Léa Falco bonsoir
et merci d'être avec nous quel parcours
vous êtes à 24 ans formatrice des agents
de la fonction publique aux enjeux du
réchauffement vous êtes sortis de
Sciences Po vous avez aussi formés les
députés à leur arrivée ici à l'Assemblée
nationale de très engagée dans la
conversion des entreprises on va en
parler et vous signez votre premier
essai aux éditions Rue de l'échiquier
faire écologie ensemble la guerre des
générations n'aura pas lieu vous allez
nous dire pourquoi tout à l'heure dans
la deuxième partie mais on commence ce
soir par le défi de l'autorité c'est le
constat partagé par tous après les nuits
d'émeutes dans les banlieues l'autorité
étant crise un peu partout en France et
c'est une crise profonde qu'elle
traverse parents école policiers élus
les figure les institutions censées
l'incarner son partout défi alors
comment la restaurer cette autorité la
droite
prône un serrage de vis à tous les
étages le lien qu'elle fait entre
l'immigration et les émeutes suscite un
tollé à gauche grand débat avec mes
invités sur ce plateau dans un instant
avant de retrouver nos parties pris nos
affranchis et puis Bourbon Express bien
sûr l'histoire du jour à l'Assemblée
voilà pour le programme ce soir vous me
suivez les à Falco ça vous regarde c'est
maintenant
[Musique]
nous avons un problème d'autorité dans
la société qui commence par la famille
déclaration d'Emmanuel Macron à
l'adresse d'élus locaux aujourd'hui lors
de sa visite à Pau la crise ne date pas
d'hier bien sûr mais les émeuses
urbaines de ces dernières nuits rend
urgente les réponses politiques ordre
calme et Concorde encore dit le chef de
l'État mais pour le concret bien le
président préfère encore attendre le
temps de se pencher finement sur les
profils des jeunes émetiés condamnés par
la justice alors en attendant c'est la
droite et le RN qui monopolise le
terrain de la fermeté bonsoir Cécile
relac et bienvenue vous êtes député
renaissance du Val-d'Oise vous êtes
professeur de PS de profession notamment
à Argenteuil vous avez exercé pendant 16
ans vous avez été aussi principal de
collèges je ne dis pas de bêtises
c'était en Seine-Saint-Denis à
Pierrefitte c'est bien cela expérience
peut-être importante pour pour ce débat
bonsoir Philippe Gosselin merci d'être
là vous êtes député des républicains de
la Manche les républicains qui proposent
une batterie de mesures c'était rue de
Vaugirard au 16 du parti pour restaurer
je cite l'ordre public on va y revenir
dans le détail bonsoir Nadir Kaya
bienvenue président de l'association
banlieue plus et nos quartiers qui fait
de l'entraide à Gennevilliers et au
Blanc-Mesnil dans le 92 enfin bonsoir
Yannis roder figure familière de cette
émission vous êtes professeur
d'histoire-géographie en
Seine-Saint-Denis directeur de
l'observatoire de l'éducation à la
Fondation Jean Jaurès Léa Falco ce qui
s'est passé dans le pays nous a
forcément tous interpeller ça nous
saisit donc n'hésitez pas à intervenir
en tant que citoyenne ou à interrogé
même nos invités on commence par planter
le décor la crise de l'autorité sous
toutes ses formes c'est le chrono de
Blacko pour commencer
et je me retourne comme chaque soir pour
vous accueillir je vous invite Léa Falco
à faire la même chose bonsoir Stéphane
blackovski bonsoir à toutes et tous
alors cette crise de l'autorité alors ce
soir on va commencer par un sonore de
Vincent Jean Brun donc je sais que
l'actualité défile à toute vitesse
j'espère que vous souvenez que c'est le
nom du maire de L'Haÿ-les-Roses dans la
famille a été agressée bien on lui a
demandé récemment quel était son
diagnostic sur les émeutes et bien voilà
ce qu'il a répondu
la société et là je parle vraiment le la
société en dansant ensemble au niveau de
l'État a considérer un moment donné que
l'autorité c'était un vilain mot que
l'autorité l'ordre c'était des vilains
mots seringue mais c'est ce qui nous
manque le plus aujourd'hui
alors cette opinion n'a rien de très
original c'est vraiment le client d'une
très très large majorité de Français
c'est un sondage qui date du mois de
mars vous voyez 85 % des Français
pensent que l'autorité est une notion
qui se perd aujourd'hui en France et
quand Vincent Jean Brun disait que le
phénomène n'était pas nouveau ben
difficile de lui donner tort regardez je
vous ai retrouvé une des échos qui date
de 2006 donc ça date il y a plus de 15
ans l'autorité était en crise et voyez
dans l'éditorial écrit pour ce numéro il
y avait marqué 3 pièces sur chahutés
agression des pompiers collèges incendie
alors on se dit bon finalement 15 ans
rien n'a changé ah bah non c'est faux
des choses vont changer parce que de
toute façon largement aggravées je vous
rappelle un peu les chiffres le nombre
de refus d'obtent tempérés a augmenté de
50% en disant le nombre d'agressions de
pompiers étaient multipliés par trois en
disant on agresse tout ce qui porte de
l'uniforme qui représente un peu
l'autorité les médecins les positionnés
regardez même les arbitres de football
se mettent en grève parce qu'ils sont
régulièrement agressés les examinateurs
d'auto-école eux aussi se plaignent
d'être victime de violence alors bien
sûr le respect de l'autorité ici on est
à l'Assemblée quand on parle de
politique publique ça se passe notamment
à l'école mais bon à l'école je trouve
que les professeurs sont justement les
premières victimes de ce rejet de
l'autorité je vous montre encore des
chiffres c'est les sondages vraiment de
de ces derniers mois 17 % donc de
manière générale en France des
enseignants étaient agressés
physiquement verbalement lors de l'année
en cours et si on parle des quartiers
difficiles donc il y a des réseaux
d'éducation prioritaire bien c'est
encore plus difficile puisque on passe à
26% de professeurs agressés alors vous
allez me dire mais bon sang est que font
les parents que font les parents
regardez ce qu'ils font les parents ils
donnent pas toujours de bon exemple
parce que parmi les agressions que
subissent les professeurs il y en a
justement pas mal qui viennent des
parents alors on repose la question que
faire je veux dire que dans cette
situation il y en a une qui est plutôt à
l'aise parce que ça fait un bout de
temps qu'elle plaide pour le retour de
l'autorité c'était même son slogan pour
la présidentielle en 2022 donc elle
avait commencé campagne dès 2021 vous
voyez avec ce slogan donc ce matin et
forcément quand on interroge elle a pas
besoin de gesticuler à Marine Le Pen
elle a pas besoin de faire de grandes
déclarations elle n'a qu'à enfoncé le
clou c'était devant Thomas Sotto
il faut taper fort serrer la vis il faut
encore une fois que l'autorité de l'État
s'exprime parce que c'est ce qui protège
la société alors en revanche du côté des
LR j'ai l'impression qu'on se sent un
petit peu en retard dans cette course à
l'autorité et donc on en rajoute un
petit peu enfin moi j'ai l'impression
que j'ai vu regarder LR réclame plus de
place de prison donc minimum 80 000
disent-ils Éric seutti lui veut couper
les allocations des parents des métiers
et puis de son côté il y a Marleix veut
envoyer les mineurs en prison bref on a
le sentiment que ça se rapproche
vraiment du programme de Marine Le Pen
mais avant de vous décélébrer je
voudrais quand même souligner un
paradoxe avant de conclure on a vu au
début que 85% des Français se plaignent
d'un recul de l'autorité mais le
paradoxe c'est que quand on nom de
français quelles sont les principaux
défauts de Emmanuel Macron m'a regardé
il est méprisant c'est sûr il est
arrogant bah oui d'accord mais son
principal défaut c'est qu'il est
autoritaire donc je vous laisse débattre
avec la situation de ce pays où tout le
monde réclame de l'autorité tout en se
plaignant d'avoir président trop
autoritaire très intéressant allez
c'était un billet un billet signé
Stéphane blackovski je vais commencer
avec vous Cécile relac quel mot vous
mettez sur cette crise de l'autorité
déjà est-ce que vous la vous la
reconnaissez vous ferez bien compte que
elle prend un aspect extrêmement aigu
avec les émeutes mais elle n'a pas
d'hier comment vous la qualifiez en
effet elle date pas dire et le billet
d'ailleurs est très très bon parce que
moi qui est malheureusement dans mes
fonctions connues
plusieurs émeutes depuis 1997 donc
aujourd'hui la crise de l'autorité donc
un elle n'est pas nouvelle de
il faut peut-être interroger et là c'est
vraiment collectivement sur comment
notre société on est arrivé en effet à
la fois réclamer à corps et à cri une
autorité mais qu'à chaque fois que l'on
met en place une mesure dite autoritaire
ou qui peut y avoir un ton autorité
d'autorité et bien on est
se dire bah non là c'est trop
l'exemple alors celui qui est le mien il
y a une histoire on en discutera
peut-être c'est un milieu qu'on connaît
très bien c'est l'enseignement justement
l'autorité dans des parents et
l'autorité des enseignants on voit bien
que les enseignants lorsqu'ils font
preuve de d'une certaine autorité face à
une classe d'élèves et bien oui en effet
de plus en plus de parents contredisent
l'autorité de l'enseignant parce que le
petit choupinet ou la petite choupinette
dans la salle de classe n'aurait jamais
pu faire ça donc elle commence cette
crise de l'autorité et cette crise vous
êtes d'accord avec le chef de l'État
là-dessus
une chose est certaine c'est que à force
de dire et très tôt justement dans
l'éducation d'un enfant de remettre en
cause la parole d'un adulte devant même
cet enfant
ça peut poser problème et politiquement
si on refait aussi un peu un retour en
arrière je vais vous parler de quelqu'un
qui Nicolas Sarkozy qui on peut pas dire
a été le moins autoritaire
il y a quelque chose que je lui reproche
beaucoup dans son discours de l'époque
de c'est lorsque justement quelque part
il a dénigré les fonctionnaires sur un
certain discours que ce soit en
supprimant les postes de policiers ou en
supprimant les postes d'enseignants
parce que quelque part dans son discours
qu'il a tenu c'était que peut-être c'est
cors de fonctionnaires la police de
proximité les enseignants et bien oui
peut-être que il a un petit peu écorné
l'autorité de ces personnes donc les
causes sont multifactorielles si je
comprends bien Philippe Gosselin bon
évidemment les premières victimes de
tout ce qui s'est passé en banlieue
c'est ce qui habitent il faut le
rappeler c'est une minorité de
délinquants qui ont pillé cassé même si
les chiffres font froids dans le dos
qu'ils tiennent leur gosse ça c'est ce
qu'a dit Eric Dupond-Moretti très
clairement les parents étaient pointés
du doigt au sommet de l'État on a même
entendu un préfet de l'Hérault dire deux
claques et au lit ça a créé la polémique
ça vous semble approprié comme réponse
au fond de punir les parents défaillants
puisque c'est ce que propose les
républicains écoutez s'il y a des causes
multiples et y compris à écouter notre
collègue Nicolas Sarkozy enfin faut être
un peu sérieux ça fait plus de 6 ans
maintenant que vous êtes au pouvoir
Emmanuel Macron a toutes les manettes
alors un peu moins depuis un an certes
mais toutes les manettes donc on peut
rechercher des responsabilités que
chacun
pour vous j'en arrive à votre à votre
question il y a des causes multiples
mais dont aussi une démission de
certains parents qui sont complètement
dépassés on peut pas généraliser moi je
crois qu'en effet je personne ne dira le
contraire que les premières victimes
sont les habitants de de ces quartiers
parce que ce sont des rares services
publics qui parfois ont été abîmés des
établissements scolaires plus de 243 des
mairies des bâtiments publics plus de
2500 bâtiments publics qui ont été
attaqués sur les parents on a vu aussi
les parents certains parents ont
totalement démissionné beaucoup de
familles monoparentales lorsque les
punir
à la misère personne ne fait le procès
par principe des familles monoparentales
mais ce n'est pas parce que vous êtes
famille monoparentale que vous devez
avoir une excuse de monoparentalité en
quelque sorte bien sûr que c'est plus
dur mais ça veut pas dire une famille
monoparentale que le papa est totalement
et en permanence absent donc vous
défendez un durcissement des règles il
faut les pas aussi ce n'est pas l'alpha
et l'oméga mais il faut aussi ramener
les parents à leur propre
responsabilités
c'était pas une simple proposition
d'Eric ciotis c'était une loi qui avait
été votée en effet sous Nicolas Sarkozy
qui avait commencé à produire ses effets
qui a été abrogé sous François Hollande
et qui n'a pas d'ailleurs été réinstauré
depuis donc c'est c'est pas une course à
l'échalote c'est retour aussi un certain
nombre d'éléments qui paraissent
fondamentaux et quand on fait la
polémique autour des propos du préfet
tout le monde avait très bien compris
que c'était pas une incitation à la
violence moi je peux vous dire en circo
90% des gens lui donnent raison donc il
faut arrêter de faire des des querelles
un peu artificielles on voyait très bien
ce qu'il voulait dire la question
centrale Yanis roder de l'autorité elle
se pose à l'école ça fait des années que
les profs des quartiers dit politique de
la ville se sentent un peu abandonnés
certains même sont dépassés vous
l'expliquez comment vous cette crise de
l'autorité
c'est d'abord je crois qu'il faut être
très humble face à ce qui nous arrive et
à ce qui est arrivé
ces derniers jours parce que non
seulement ces multifactoriels mais
bienheureux celles ou celui qui a
l'explication et qui permet de
comprendre complètement la situation
donc l'école bien sûr que l'école joue
un rôle les doigts jouer un rôle les
professeurs doivent jouer un rôle mais
vous savez l'école elle est d'abord
aussi le réceptacle de ce qui se passe
dans la société et quand dès la
maternelle ou dès l'école primaire vous
avez des enfants qui sont problématiques
en classe ça me permet d'ailleurs de
dire que ils ne sont pas si nombreux que
ça et je crois que ceux qui ont détruit
c'est l'équivalent si vous voulez de 1 2
peut-être 3 élèves compliqués dans les
quartiers difficiles que nous avons par
classe et cela c'est cela que nous
trouvons dans la rue ça veut dire aussi
que les l'immenses majorité de nos
élèves n'étaient pas dans la rue n'ont
pas discuté avec vos élèves même si
c'était les vacances ou avec leurs
parents pendant ces nuits d'émeutes avec
les élèves moins avec leurs parents vous
savez aujourd'hui voilà on a des groupes
WhatsApp Instagram voilà qu'on discute
les questions que m'ont posé mes élèves
les quelques-uns avec qui j'ai pu
discuter était très simple qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez monsieur voilà qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez monsieur alors ça
veut dire quoi qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez monsieur de mon point de vue de
l'enseignant que je suis c'est votre
avis compte et l'autorité de
l'enseignant elle est d'abord là c'est à
dire que un enseignant il maintient
l'autorité en classe non pas à part
autoritarisme parce qu'il faut pas
confondre autorité autoritarisme
l'autorité elle est d'abord
intellectuelle celle de l'enseignant
elle est intellectuelle elle est bien
sûr dans sa posture c'est très important
mais c'est d'abord une autorité
intellectuelle à partir du moment où ces
élèves quels qu'ils soient
reconnaissants en vous en l'enseignant
exactement et là vous pouvez travailler
ce qui n'empêche pas que ça ne règle pas
le problème des deux ou trois dont je
parlais en début d'intervention qui eux
rencontrent des vrais problèmes
personnels qui sont parfois
déstructuellement
ça peut être cela mais et c'est d'abord
cela je crois effectivement parce que ce
sont des élèves vous savez en
psychologie en psychiatrie on parle de
toute puissance ce sont des élèves qui
n'ont jamais eu accès à la frustration
c'est à dire qu'ils ne supportent pas la
limite ils ne connaissent pas la limite
donc il ne supporte pas la frustration
ce sont des élèves qui font des crises
ce sont des élèves qui sont extrêmement
compliqués à gérer mais si cela que l'on
retrouve et qui veulent tout tout de
suite qui sont dans l'immédiateté alors
Nader Kaya c'est pas évident de parler
de ces jeunes là parce que tous les
reportages le montrent c'est très
difficile de les approcher surtout pour
les journalistes alors il y a beaucoup
de portraits qui ont été faits par leurs
entourage vous vous avez pu parler à ces
jeunes qui ont monté des barricades
pendant ces nuits d'émeutes ou est-ce
que vous pouvez nous dire pourquoi ils
s'en sont pris aux institutions de la
République à leur propre école à la
préfecture à la mairie
alors c'est très compliqué parce que ça
a été évoqué juste avant il y a des
responsabilités à tous les niveaux et
des secteurs qui sont pratiquement en
faillite partout que ça soit au niveau
de l'éducation nationale que ça soit au
niveau de l'autorité ou de la
responsabilité des parents notamment
aujourd'hui si vous voulez les banlieues
et les jeunes qui sont là sont à l'image
de la France et de la société en général
mais aussi de la situation
internationale on vit une époque assez
difficile ou parfois les parents
eux-mêmes ont déjà du mal à avoir une
place de parent et d'assumer leur
responsabilité après la transmission de
l'autorité par les parents moi je pense
qu'il y a des mots qu'on oublie beaucoup
aujourd'hui et j'ai relu un petit
quelques passages de notre Constitution
à tous
qui nous parle de bonheur qui nous parle
de mépris qui nous parle d'oubli
d'ignorance et il y a des choses et des
mots qu'il faut savoir remettre à leur
place et qu'il faut savoir aborder sans
aucun souci aujourd'hui il y a des mots
qui sont imposés par la classe politique
et notamment par la gauche ou la droite
en terme une pression en termes de de
violence aussi de la part de l'autorité
qui passe très très mal dans les
quartiers populaires pourquoi
la mort de Naël la violence le chaos est
une excusable non mais il s'explique on
peut le comprendre après par rapport à
la situation des quartiers populaires
c'est compliqué parce qu'il y a un
passif de 40 ans bien évidemment
monsieur Macron n'est pas responsable de
tout mais il est quand même en
responsabilité aujourd'hui lui qui
venait avec une pancarte ni droite ni de
gauche avec la prétention de vouloir
faire autrement on s'aperçoit que tout
doucement il a pris le costume de ses de
ses de ses pairs c'est-à-dire à gauche
et à droite et il a aujourd'hui une
posture notamment en termes d'autorité
qui n'est pas celle qu'on a pu connaître
de la part de d'un politique comme
Chirac ou Mitterrand à l'époque déjà
lui-même en termes d'autorité
en terme de d'autorité ne donne pas
l'exemple quand on voit un petit peu ces
différentes postures qu'il a pu avoir
dans les réseaux sociaux avec certaines
personnes il a un peu quelque part
dévalorisé le statut de président de la
République mais sur les écoles vous avez
vu cette vidéo cette mère de famille qui
court la nuit non pas l'école elle
demande à ses jeunes
pourquoi l'école est ciblée selon vous
est-ce qu'il y a une forme de comment
dire d'inconscient à s'attaquer j'ai
entendu beaucoup de choses à la télé de
la part de d'hommes politiques qui
parlait de posture politique pas du tout
ce sont et quand je dis ça moi je
condamne les violences je n'excuse pas
mais j'essaie de de participer à
l'explication et à la compréhension des
choses c'est très compliqué ces jeunes
là déjà moi en tant que parents je
comprends pas pourquoi ils étaient
dehors vous avez aussi des jeunes qui le
sont souvent même sans avoir des émeutes
donc là effectivement on peut remettre
en question la responsabilité des
parents moi-même j'ai lancé un appel à
la conscientisation et à la
responsabilité des parents dans le
quartier populaire notamment par rapport
aux réalités qu'on ne veut pas regarder
de nous en interne c'est à dire les
incivilités les trafics de drogue ce
sont les premières nuisances dans nos
quartiers on peut regarder bien
évidemment de l'autre côté en parlant du
racisme la discrimination des inégalités
c'est c'est un fait
pour les quartiers populaires alors sur
la posture des hommes politiques et des
femmes politiques aujourd'hui si vous
voulez pour avoir côtoyé un peu le monde
politique je pense qu'il y a pas de
volonté réelle de résoudre les problèmes
dans le quartier populaire
bien évidemment on a parlé de du fait
qu'il n'y ait pas de baguette magique et
de solutions magiques il faut revenir au
fondamentaux les fondamentaux ce sont la
Constitution française et les valeurs
universelles qui est censée porter le
président de la République au quotidien
et pas simplement quand il y a des
émeutes ou alors monsieur le garde des
sceaux à venir nous donner des leçons
sur les parents quand il y a une
situation aussi violente un moment donné
on est censé répondre avec des mots
justes et des actions concrètes et donc
ça j'entends bien mais
tous les soirs on décline une
problématique très précis hier on a
parlé de la relation police population
on a parlé des maires ce soir on essaye
de questionner cette cette notion cette
question de l'autorité qui manifestement
est en pleine affaissement ça je pense
qu'on peut tous être d'accord là-dessus
Philippe Gosselin est-ce que vous pensez
que la batterie de réponse que vous
proposez aujourd'hui va changer les
choses est-ce que c'est par la
répression en gros vous responsabiliser
les parents par la punition par des
peines difficile les allocations
familiales parfois même les expulsions
de HLM et puis les enfants parce que
vous voulez renforcer la justice pénale
des mineurs en créant des prisons pour
jeunes des centres plus de centres
éducatifs fermés et en abaissant la
majorité pénale à 16 ans pourquoi
pour vous ce serait efficace pour
refaire revenir l'autorité pas
évidemment réduire les solutions aux
problèmes de de cité ou de quartier
uniquement à des aspects de répression
et d'autorité on est bien d'accord bien
ce que vous proposez attendez attendez
aujourd'hui on est sur une demande de
fermeté et d'autorité c'est le sujet de
de ce soir mais je reviens deux petites
secondes sur ce qu'il disait mon voisin
on ne peut pas dire que il y a pas de
moyens qui a été mis à disposition des
politiques de la ville de l'habitat
c'est pas vrai il y a eu des dizaines et
des dizaines de milliards non donc il
faut aussi quand même regarder ce qui a
été fait on peut pas laisser dire il y a
eu beaucoup de choses on avait Catherine
Vautrin ici de laurue qui vous a parlé
de l'habitat mais il y a l'humain aussi
bien sûr
personne ne dit le contraire et je
rappelle aussi quand même qu'on a dans
ces quartiers des tas de gens qui
travaillent qui payent des impôts qui
sont des gens bien j'ai pas de
difficultés à le dire maintenant nous ce
que l'on veut faire passer c'est que
effectivement il faut arrêter un peu le
côté bisounours
les parents parfois sont dépassés et
bien les parents dépassés on peut les
prendre en charge les accompagner il y a
des il y a des Asos qui le font etc mais
il y a un moment où ça suffit pas et et
il faut un peu responsabiliser et je
suis désolé on fera pas non plus des
miracles des peines minimales à la
première connerie je cite c'est ce qu'a
proposé Emmanuel Macron il y a quand
même un certain nombre de jeunes qui
sont relâchés il y a même pas de rappel
à la loi etc ça va pas enfin il faut
aussi que qu'il y ait un sentiment de de
ne pas respecter les codes et quand on
ne respecte pas les codes et bien on en
pense
pas à cela mais il y a aussi un moment
où un peu de laisser faire je vais vous
faire le vieux réac ça va vous faire
sourire mais de depuis pas loin de 60
ans le interdire d'interdire à aussi
dans
la dans le méchant bien que je provoquer
des réactions un peu mais c'est un petit
peu tout cela
et encore une fois ça ne se résume pas
qu'à ça il y a des éléments sociaux
économiques bien évidemment mais il y a
aussi ces éléments d'autorité donc il
faut un peu rappeler chacun à ses
responsabilités
c'est l'expression du chef de l'État
alors il a pas fait de grand discours
d'annonce il se donne du temps on a
compris mais on voit bien que cette
question de la justice pénale risque
d'être au rendez-vous des des annonces
concrètes aujourd'hui déjà la sévérité
des peines prononcées en comparution
immé a été souligné en 76% des personnes
jugées ont été placées en détention 31%
des gardes à vue concernaient des
mineurs ce qu'il faut aller plus loin
pour moi il faut pas aller plus loin on
est déjà allés très loin je vous
rappelle qu'on a modifié d'ailleurs le
code de l'ordonnance de 45 et ça a été
appliqué le 2021 donc il y a déjà des
choses qui ont été il y a des gens qui
qui existent et justement l'injustice ce
qui s'est passé ce week-end parce que en
tout cas dans mon département dans le
Val-d'Oise pour je crois c'est la
première fois le tribunal de Pontoise a
fonctionné parce qu'il y a eu une
coordination police justice qui a fait
que justement on était dans la réponse
immédiate qui est nécessaire
particulièrement lorsque on s'adresse
aux plus jeunes ça tous les enseignants
le savent si vous posez une peine ne
serait-ce que un mois deux mois ou après
la bêtise et bien pour la compréhension
de l'erreur c'est difficile donc
je vais pas
à votre question sur aujourd'hui je
pense qu'on a déjà beaucoup de choses
qui ont été faites qui sont dans la loi
les tribunaux s'en sont saisis
maintenant vous si vous me demandez
qu'il faut aller encore plus loin
abaisser le seuil pénal moi je réponds
aussi toujours à cette ambiguïté qu'on
nous concitoyens c'est-à-dire ou dans un
département comme le mois comme le mien
ou on doit construire une prison tout le
monde veut la prison mais personne ne
l'a veut à côté de chez soi tout le
monde veut un centre fermé de rétention
de mineurs mais on ne le veut pas à côté
de chez soi lorsque l'on veut construire
un accueil donc ce sont des solutions
simples pour voilà simplement je
voudrais revenir sur un point qui est
très important que la parentalité c'est
l'accompagnement la parentalité moi il y
a une phrase j'ai été donc à midi comme
beaucoup d'élus on était sur les parvis
des mairies justement on soutien et on
soutien à beaucoup en fait à nos
gendarmes à nos forces de police à vous
de soi et moi pour la première fois j'ai
une maman qui est venue me voir et dans
notre discussion à un moment il m'a dit
mais redonner nous notre autorité
je vous ça m'a interpellé pourquoi cette
maman est-ce que ça se demander de lui
redonner ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
que dans certaines nos quartiers je suis
sur un territoire où il y a en effet des
quartiers populaires très populaires ça
veut dire que aussi dans le discours et
c'est pas la première fois où en fait je
me suis rendu compte que j'ai entendu ça
de certains parents particulièrement les
parents les plus éloignés de
institutions qui n'ont pas forcément les
codes sociaux et que non pas la bonne
compréhension des choses en fait leurs
enfants leur font croire aussi que ils
ont énormément de droits et que c'est
les parents qui vont être punis et dans
cette réaction de cette maman me dire
mais redonnez-nous notre autorité ça
veut bien dire que beaucoup de parents
aussi ne sont peut-être pas
démissionnaires mais qu'ils n'ont pas
aussi aujourd'hui les codes et les
moyens de pouvoir réagir à la société
dans laquelle vivent leurs enfants le
point rupture générationnel les réseaux
sociaux quand on voit le l'importance
des réseaux sociaux ce qui s'est passé
dans les émeutes
et bien c'est vrai qu'on a peut-être du
mal à comprendre comment les jeunes
interagissent entre eux Yanis roder pour
pour l'école et puis je vous donne la
parole ou minuit vos enfants
sur l'école on n'explique pas tout j'ai
graine un peu les propositions de LR
parce que elles sont dans le débat
aujourd'hui une uniforme une tenue
unique à l'école cette proposition
revient dans le débat régulièrement
est-ce que vous pensez que ça pourrait
servir au fond à régler un certain
nombre de problèmes à restaurer
l'autorité du professeur ou ses
cosmétiques c'est du gadget alors je
crois que l'uniforme n'a pas grand chose
à voir avec l'autorité en réalité et
l'uniforme peut peut-être avoir une
utilité pour créer du essayer de créer
du commun et et faire comprendre que que
et faire comprendre que l'école c'est la
société c'est l'organisation d'une
communauté politique en petit si vous
voulez mais je crois que le problème
enfin ça ne résoudrait pas le problème
de fond parce que le problème de fond
excusez-moi de revenir à ça
des familles mais il tue pas il ne
touchent pas toutes les familles moi
j'ai la plupart de mes élèves ils sont
structurés avec des parents
en revanche l'école n'est pas capable
aujourd'hui n'est pas en situation
d'aider les parents qui sont dans la
difficulté parce que être parent je
pense que je vais apprendre à personne
c'est parfois compliqué c'est parfois
difficile et même quand ça se passe bien
c'est parfois compliqué donc c'est le
rôle de qui oui c'est pas l'école c'est
pas le rôle de l'école de venir voir où
s'immiscer
si vous me laissez terminé et d'ailleurs
je tiens à vous dire que l'école elle
fonctionne contrairement à ce que vous
dites quand j'ai pas dit le contraire
pas très bien elle fonctionne l'école
fonctionne la plupart du temps grâce à
l'engagement des enseignants qui sont
évidemment là-dessus je voulais te dire
simplement que l'école aujourd'hui n'est
pas capable de venir en aide aux
quelques enfants que les professeurs des
écoles ont en face d'eux et qui ont on
voit très bien qu'on qu'on peut
diagnostiquer très vite comme étant en
souffrance par leur agitation par leur
incapacité à rentrer dans les
apprentissages par leur les interactions
il y a aujourd'hui ce qu'on appelle les
plus les grands décrocheurs
ce sont des professeurs spécialisés qui
sont qui étaient là pour venir en aide
Nicolas Sarkozy a supprimé ses razèdes
quasiment alors on en a remis un peu
mais on n'a pas remis assez et d'autre
part on manque de structures
médico-éducatives ou médico-social avec
des psy avec des orthophonistes pour
venir en aide à ces familles et à ses
enfants pour avoir un rendez-vous psy il
faut un an dans certains quartiers
comment voulez-vous traiter des enfants
qui sont en souffrance et qui et qui
sont en souffrance personnellement mais
qui font souffrir aussi autour d'eux si
on n'a pas les moyens de prendre en
charge ces enfants Madère Kaya non je
suis d'accord avec vous bon vous m'avez
interpellé sur ce que j'ai dit mais j'ai
pas eu le temps de développer donc c'est
peut-être l'aperçu que vous avez eu de
mes propres c'est pas très grave moi je
suis pour défendre l'école parce que je
vois aussi la réalité dans les quartiers
populaires dans les villes populaires
les disparités qui peut y avoir entre
les en termes de moyens de normes aussi
vous avez des établissements encore
aujourd'hui dans 93 qui sont pas qui
sont pas aux normes et pourtant vous
êtes là quand même à enseigner vous avez
du côté de Marseille aussi moi ce qui me
désole dans le discours politique
notamment de la droite et de l'extrême
droite c'est vous leur faire croire aux
Français qu'en étant plus autorité ou en
imposant un peu plus d'autorité avec des
moyens pour taper bien évidemment sur
les plus faibles qui ont déjà les
problèmes taper sur les allocations
familiales on va régler les problèmes ça
c'est c'est démagogique c'est surtout
stupide si je peux me permettre c'est
pas la problème en France le problème en
France c'est pas simplement un problème
de justice c'est un problème d'équité
c'est qu'un moment donné quand vous avez
des des familles ou des personnes qui
sont en difficulté c'est de rajouter ce
qui ne va pas pour qu'ils atteignent un
niveau en terme d'équilibre notamment
par rapport à d'autres familles qui
vivent dans le même contente là ce qui
est important moi je pense l'école c'est
quand même le pilier principal de notre
République donc à un moment donné si on
n'a pas compris que c'est là qu'il faut
mettre au maximum de moyens et faire
croire et en plus de CRS ou en tapant
sur les familles de délinquant on va
réussir à ramener l'autorité à régler
les problèmes c'est utopique et c'est
surtout malhonnête de la part des
politiques alors il y a un sujet qui
fâche vous allez le voir on va d'aborder
pour ça dernière partie de débat parce
que ça suscité un tollé à gauche je le
disais dans le sommaire le le
gouvernement et la droite s'oppose sur
la question identitaire même si 90% des
personnes interpellaient son française
les républicains voient un lien direct
entre l'immigration et les émeutes
explications m'a été vraiment
c'est une évidence pour les républicains
les émeutes sont à relier à
l'immigration des Français donc des
jeunes qui ont
une carte d'identité française sont
tentés par un repli communautaire comme
un retour vers les origines alors que
souvent la première génération
leur idéal c'était d'intégrer de plein
pied
cette citoyenneté française si demain on
veut mieux assimiler mieux intégré il
faut tarir les flux tarir les flux
migratoires pour en finir avec les
violences
urbaines des propos condamnés par la
gauche et par le gouvernement qui
rappelle les chiffres
90% des 4000 interpellés étaient
français qui sont ces gens oui il y a
des gens qui apparemment pourraient être
issus d'immigration mais il y a eu
beaucoup de Kevin et Matteo si je peux
me permettre
il y en a eu aussi l'explication
seulement identitaire me paraît très
erronée on peut nier le problème comme
le fait monsieur Darmanin mais si on le
nie aujourd'hui il sera beaucoup
beaucoup plus grave encore demain voilà
les Français le savent qui était au cœur
des émeutes voilà pas besoin de faire
appel à des prénoms certains à droite
s'interrogent même sur la notion de
français la plupart des gens qui sont
arrêtés sont français d'accord mais ça
ne veut plus rien dire aujourd'hui ils
sont comment en français puisqu'ils ont
une haine de la France que moi élue
malheureusement depuis quelques années
je n'ai jamais ressenti comme je le
ressens aujourd'hui depuis l'embrasement
des quartiers la droite durcit son
discours pour mettre la pression sur
l'exécutif en attendant la présentation
de son projet de loi sur l'immigration
je commence avec vous vous reconnaissez
dans les propos de cette sénatrice
de d'immigration en France qui est sur
la table depuis un an et demi deux ans
et que le gouvernement diffère de moi en
moins etc et donc on n'a pas fait des
propositions avec ces événements ça date
d'avant donc il faut remettre la
chronologie pour une part par ailleurs
personne n'a identité
la cause unique de ce qui est arrivé
aujourd'hui mais je pense oui en effet
que dans certains quartiers il y a bien
une question
identitaire c'est pas parce qu'on est
français et 9 ou 90% des jeunes qui
étaient en cause son français
juridiquement c'est pas ça le souci mais
je crois qu'il y a bien aussi une
question d'identité certains ont du mal
à se retrouver dans les éléments de la
société française je fais pas le procès
de tout les naturalisés ou ceux qui sont
devenus Français de la deuxième ou
troisième génération
mais il y a des
l'archipel voilà français dont on a
marqué il y a pas si longtemps ce livre
qui s'est arraché comme des petits pains
voilà c'est c'est on le découvre pas
simplement maintenant donc vouloir dire
que ce n'est que l'immigration c'est
évidemment faux et quand bien même il
n'y aurait aucune immigration demain ce
qui me paraît difficile à tenir dans
tous les cas il y a bien aujourd'hui un
problème dans certains territoires avec
certaines parties de la population je ne
dis pas tout le monde un problème qu'il
ne faut pas mettre sous le tapis
c'est le relax cette lecture
identitaire que fait la droite de ses
émeutes elle est complètement fausse
pour vous je dirais même qu'elle est
adjacte c'est
moi qui ai grandi justement avec des
amis qui étaient blagues longueurs et
qui venait justement d'un certain grand
nombre de quartiers d'ailleurs que vous
connaissez très très bien non non
justement lorsque l'on connaît les
quartiers et que l'on connaît la
population des quartiers ça fait 40 ans
que justement que il y a un ressentiment
il y a un sentiment d'injustice un monde
relégation qui fait parce que c'est
certaines personnes qui habitent dans
ces quartiers on ne les a justement
toujours que qualifiés que par rapport à
soit une origine soit une appartenance
sociale soit une religion et à chaque
fois ils étaient pas à la bonne place ou
au bon moment une forme de régression
vers les origines éthiques c'est ce que
dit Bruno Retailleau oui mais ça et ça
c'est pas là c'est justement en tenant
ses propos là qu'on va jeter de l'huile
sur le feu dans nos quartiers et pour
cela il faut connaître la population des
quartiers et il faut aussi parler un
petit peu leur langage et il faut aussi
accepter que dans ces quartiers là on a
énormément mais c'est la majorité qui
veulent s'en sortir qui travaillent qui
des jeunes qui sont qui ont des
ressources je peux vous assurer
inimaginable et bien j'aimerais qu'on
puisse plus mettre en valeur aussi ces
quartiers là et il y a quelque chose
dont on ne parle pas qui est la
ghettoïsation on peut la reparler mais
elle est arrivée à un moment lorsque
vous êtes toujours au même endroit et
qu'en effet on manque de médecins on
manque d'enseignants que les enseignants
n'habitent plus dans les quartiers que
les policiers n'avaient plus dans les
quartiers
suis pas d'accord sur cette lecture-là
si je reviens à votre question
d'identité
à son origine et où on est étiqueté et
les propos de Madame Monsieur de vouloir
graduer les Français c'est quoi c'est
par rapport à la carte d'identité si on
a 99 sur sa carte de sécurité sociale si
jamais on est la première de la deuxième
génération on vaut peut-être mieux de
quelqu'un qui est né sur le territoire
français
de traiter la question il y a une
enseignante qui s'appelle Fatiha
boudjalat qui est principale de collège
aujourd'hui qui a écrit un livre qui
s'appelle les nostalgiade qui dit qu'il
y a des étudiants enfin des élèves qui
qui n'ont jamais mis les pieds en
Algérie et qui parle du bled comme d'un
paradis rêvé est-ce que ça existe ça
alors qu'elle leur disait mais vous
savez c'est pas si gay dans ce pays-là
est-ce que ça ça existe pour vous est-ce
que ce sujet là il faut le toucher du
doigt ou c'est faire fausse route alors
moi je suis pas politisée donc j'ai pas
de tabou je peux parler de tout j'ai pas
de souci je peux dire ce qui ne va pas
dans les quartiers populaires on
pourrait faire des heures là dessus et
on va peut-être m'étiqueter comme étant
de du rassemblement national
moi je vais vous dire une chose je vais
vous parler de mon expérience c'est
celle que je connais le mieux je vais
pas rentrer dans les débats idéologiques
quand j'avais 20h 20 ans je me sentais
pas français pourquoi parce qu'on a les
débats qu'on a les débats aujourd'hui
c'est à dire qu'on traitait par rapport
à mes origines ou celle de mes parents
on était beaucoup comme ça j'ai évolué
j'ai grandi aujourd'hui j'assume
pleinement ma double identité parce que
comme des millions de Français j'ai une
double identité je suis français à
l'Algérien je suis pas 55 ans je suis
100% des deux côtés en tant que Français
aujourd'hui et en plus comme vous le
disiez dans le quartier populaire
beaucoup de de nos concitoyens porte
fièrement les couleurs de la France
notamment dans le domaine sportif dans
le domaine de artistique à tous les
niveaux donc aujourd'hui ce qui est
malsain c'est que par rapport à cette
violence on a des catégories de vue on
va se focaliser là-dessus on va voir un
débat qui est celui que qui aime
absorber l'opinion publique c'est-à-dire
un débat identitaire où on va on va
jamais trouver de solution parce qu'on
oppose les alors il y a un mot qui a pas
été prononcé c'est celui-là la réalité
notamment les causes de cette situation
c'est quand même la mort de du petit
jeune Naël mais qui n'est pas la
première depuis 40 ans donc ça si on
continue à regarder de l'autre côté en
oubliant ce qui se passe là et on
revient sur le fait que certains ne se
sentent pas français mais moi je peux
vous l'expliquer pas besoin d'être
philosophe ou scientifique c'est parce
que aussi ils sont pas aimé en tant que
tel ils sont pas reconnus en tant que
telle c'est aussi simple que ça et pas
besoin de faire de la psychologie on
parlait d'autorité il faut donner de
l'amour j'ai parlé de mots qu'on entend
pas très souvent politique on parle
d'amour de bienveillance de partage de
solidarité c'est peut-être des mois à
gauche désolé je suis pas gauchiste non
plus mais c'est des mots qui sont
surtout humains et équilibrés donc à un
moment donné il faut aussi avoir ces
mots là aussi pour ces jeunes là il faut
les considérer puis la République a des
devoirs notamment vis-à-vis de ses
envois ses enfants là de les considérer
comme n'importe quel enfant aujourd'hui
malheureusement c'est pas le cas donc à
un moment donné
sur sur cette lecture identitaire vous
vous êtes enseignant qu'est-ce que de
quoi vous pouvez témoigner est-ce que ça
existe ou ça n'existe pas
je crois qu'il faut pas se voiler la
face il y a des questions d'identité qui
se posent il y a des questions
d'identité qui se posent à titre
individuel vous en avez parlé il y a
aussi des questions d'identitaire ou
d'identité qui se posent en termes
collectif si on écoute ce que disent une
partie des jeunes il y a des choses qui
les structurent l'identité elle est
structurée par plusieurs facteurs il y a
parfois un facteur religieux qui
intervient il y a parfois le facteur de
l'origine mais ce n'est jamais évacuer
en réalité c'est présent c'est là donc
moi ce que je dis c'est que il faut
absolument que la République à travers
l’école à travers les discours des
discours républicains intégrateurs
puissent faire comprendre que nous
sommes là pour construire du commun et
avoir un projet tous ensemble on va
s'arrêter sur cette note là construire
du commun ensemble merci beaucoup merci
à vous d'être venu débattre sur LCP
j'aurais aimé vous donner la parole je
vous prie de m'excuser mais le débat
était assez dense vous restez avec moi
dans une dizaine de minutes les de nos
affranchis ce soir on va poursuivre ce
débat d'ailleurs sur l'autorité avec le
philosophe Pierre-Henri tavoyau qui va
revenir à l'origine de la notion
l'enseignement de l'écologie à l'école
ça va vous intéresser les alphas donc
qu'est-ce que c'est vraiment une
priorité s'interroge Carole Barjon et
puis dans Bourbon Express ce soir de
quoi nous parlez-vous Elsa elles avaient
de la LPM la loi de programmation
militaire c'est un peu plus compliqué
que prévu pour le gouvernement mais
d'abord on va parler de vous Léa Falco
et de votre livre faire écologie
ensemble aux éditions Rue de l'échiquier
vous croyez à la collaboration des
boomers et des plus jeunes de toutes les
générations et même des riches et des
pauvres sur la transition écologique on
va en parler ensemble juste après
l'invitation d'Hélène Bonduelle regardez
[Musique]
à l'action violente où la désobéissance
civile vous préférez l'argumentation et
le fond comme lorsque vous participez à
une campagne dans le métro pour
démocratiser le rapport du GIEC ou à une
formation accélérée aux enjeux
climatiques pour les nouveaux députés
votre credo c'est infuser de la
transformation écologique dans les
esprits des politiques des grandes
écoles et des entreprises il faut
changer les choses de l'intérieur
peut-être que certains dans la salle ont
été tentés où sont aujourd'hui aussi
parce cette idée de déserté parce que
vous avez énormément évolué en moins
d'un an parce que peut-être que vous
avez une forme de dissonance cognitive
par rapport à vos entreprises maintenant
que vous trouvez qu'elle vont pas assez
vite que vous trouvez qu'elles vont pas
assez loin mais nous on vous demande
aussi de rester parce qu'on a besoin de
gens qui restent y compris quand c'est
dur et surtout quand c'est dur
vous dites qu'être écolo aujourd'hui ça
ne doit pas être de l'abnégation que
nous devons tondre à une écologie par
défaut
alors Léa Falco nous avons une question
cette écologie par défaut est-elle
entrée dans le logiciel gouvernemental
réponse cfalco ça fait partie des
réponses faciles donc pour l'instant non
pour avoir une écologie par défaut il
faut qu'on modifie les infrastructures
sociales dans lesquelles on vit écologie
par défaut c'est par réflexe c'est
systématique alors même pas par réflexe
c'est qu'on a pas besoin de faire
d'effort pour que notre premier choix le
tropion par défaut notre option par
design soit écologique donc c'est à dire
que moi j'habite à Paris pour venir ici
j'ai pu prendre un métro mon option par
défaut c'est pas des logiciel du
gouvernement pour ça disons que il y a
une transformation tellement énorme à
faire par rapport à la société dans
laquelle on vit aujourd'hui que ça se
fait nécessairement sur le temps il y a
deux mots qui ont été prononcés
planification on va voir quelles seront
les arbitrages financiers pour secteur
par secteur à arriver à des objectifs de
neutralité carbone 2050 2030 aussi et
puis il y a il y a l'adaptation c'est
quand même un changement de logiciel on
travaille sur un scénario à plus 4
degrés même si personne ne le souhaite
ça suffit pas ça n'avance pas assez vite
non mais alors il y a de l'action il y a
de l'action climatique et de l'action
environnementale il ne se passe pas rien
ça c'est important de le dire aussi on
ne va certainement pas assez vite mais
il se passe pas rien et non seulement il
y a l'atténuation donc c'est à dire la
réduction des gaz à effet de serre mais
en plus puisque vous avez une inertie
climatique d'à peu près 20 ans notre
futur climatique n'est pas déterminé on
ne sait pas encore dans quel scénario on
va se trouver et donc à côté il faut
adapter nos sociétés effectivement et
donc ça c'est seulement le réchauffement
climatique mais à côté on a d'autres
soucis environnementaux qui compliquent
un petit peu l'image et notamment sur la
question des sols est-ce que nos sols
seront encore fertiles dans 40 ou 50 ans
comment est-ce qu'on fait pour les
préserver sur la question de la
biodiversité de la pollution des eaux de
la pollution de l'air de la pollution
des sols et donc évidemment systémique
et extrêmement complexe et ça prend en
compte aussi les enjeux sociaux
évidemment parce que disons que dans une
société on a envie de continuer à être
en démocratie on a envie justement j'en
ai envie que les inégalités se réduisent
et donc il faut pouvoir prendre tout ça
en compte vu l'ampleur des efforts à
faire puisque c'est systémique la
démocratie vous pensez que c'est quand
même le meilleur système pour parvenir à
lutter pour le climat j'en va réussir à
faire ses efforts et à faire partager
par des votes par une majorité les
décisions à prendre en fait les gens ne
vont pas pour le climat il faut pas que
les gens votent pour sauvegarder le
climat ou pour préserver les petites
grenouilles ce qui motive les gens et
c'est tout à fait normal ce qui vous
motive vous et moi aussi c'est de nous
assurer une belle vie et d'assurer à ce
qu'on aime à nos enfants à nos proches
une vie meilleure et donc il y a quelque
chose à construire autour d'un projet de
société écologique qui fondamentalement
je pense améliorer la situation de un
grand nombre de gens en France et qui se
déclinent sur ces thèmes là ce qui me
fera c'est que vous n'êtes pas une
écologie c'est de l'Apocalypse loin de
là ni de la peur vous êtes plutôt
rationnel énorme bûcheuse vous les ai
les 1000 pages de chaque rapport du GIEC
oui mais quand même il faut il faut le
faire
comment comment vous aimez à vous
définir parce qu'on a beaucoup de
visages notamment féminin d'ailleurs
dans dans cette lutte pour pour le
climat si vous êtes la pragmatique ça
vous convient oui ça me va pragmatique
ça veut dire avancer efficacement mais
en fait vous pourriez me définir comme
radical aussi puisque radical ça veut
dire en latin radix ça veut dire aller à
la racine et face à l'ampleur des
problèmes on va être obligé de les résou
racines s'il y a des gens qui nous
regardent qui sont qui jardinent et qui
aiment jardiner ils savent très bien que
si ils retirent une mauvaise herbe du
sol sans enlever la racine elle
repoussera et donc on efface un problème
une petite donc les radicaux et les
pragmatiques ont le même objectif ici et
bien sûr que ça la même méthode le
déclic qui s'est produit aux États-Unis
c'est ça oui ça a été progressif mais
disons qu'il y a des sociétés qui sont
qui sont plus difficiles difficilement
transformables que d'autres vous êtes
partis les États-Unis effectivement où
j'étais étudiante ce sont construites
est un pays qui s'est construit sur la
société de consommation et plus
largement sur le pétrole et donc il y a
une grande difficulté à transformer ces
endroits là vous êtes on l'entend
extrêmement cortiquées sur la question
climatique et en même temps vous avez
arrêté de prendre l'avion et en même
temps vous avez arrêté la viande c'est
ce que vous dites aux jeunes
d'aujourd'hui ou est-ce que on peut ne
pas forcément suivre Jean-Marc Jancovici
et essayer voilà de sauver la planète en
se limitant à quatre vols par vie alors
déjà c'est pas la planète qu'on sauve
c'est nous et nos conditions de la sur
l'avion on ne va pas pouvoir prendre
l'avion comme on le prend aujourd'hui et
4 fois dans une vie j'ai pas fait les
calculs il paraît qu'il les a fait ça me
paraît effectivement quelque chose dans
lequel on pourrait continuer à vivre
mais vous voyez typiquement sur cette
question de l'avion déjà tout le monde
le prend pas en France 70 % des Français
ne prennent pas l'avion donc c'est pas
si compliqué ces gens ces gens-là se
débrouillent et à côté vous avez une
question de comment est-ce que en
fermant certains droits j'aurais pu le
droit aujourd'hui j'ai le droit si je
sors du studio et que je vais à Orly de
prendre un vol pour où je veux et de
revenir immédiatement dans un monde en
transformation écologique on aura pu le
droit de faire ça ça veut dire qu'à côté
il faut ouvrir de nouveaux droits des
droits à des vacances proches des droits
des trains qui sont abordables des
destinations auxquelles on a accès
facilement et donc transformer très loin
en train c'est ça peut-être qu'il faut
repenser notre rapport au temps et se
dire que une ou deux fois dans une vie
si on en a envie on peut prendre six
mois un an ou deux ans de pause pour
partir loin en train ensemble l'écologie
avec les générations ça ça semble quand
même assez possible en revanche avec les
catégories les moins aisées c'est plus
difficile elles sont percutées cette
fameuse dico de mie fin du mois fin du
monde comment on fait très concrètement
pour essayer de partir ensemble dans ce
combat tout en gardant la justice
sociale au cœur c'est juste dire alors
deux choses la première est que les
désirs qu'on a aujourd'hui en tant que
société et en tant qu'individu ils sont
ils sont forcément construits par
l'environnement dans lequel on vit et
donc par une société qui nous propose de
la publicité qui nous propose
l'accumulation ou la possession comme
valeur cardinale et comme parents de la
réussite donc d'une part il faut réussir
à créer de nouveaux imaginaires autour
duquel s'articulent la notion de bonheur
positif absolument et d'autre part
désirer l'avenir dans les limites
planétaires absolument ça ressemble à
quoi un récit comme ça oh bah écoutez ça
c'est à construire ensemble mais en tout
cas mon deuxième point c'est que on est
dans une certaine mesure déterminée par
les structures sociales dans lesquelles
on évolue et j'y revient mais c'est ça
qui est fondamental c'est qu'en fait la
difficulté aujourd'hui n'est pas de
n'est pas entre guillemets de convaincre
les pauvres que il faut il faut agir
pour la planète c'est en fait de plutôt
de convaincre les riches et ceux qui
aujourd'hui peuvent se permettre
d'utiliser leur argent pour détruire le
parcours financièrement non seulement
que les taxé financièrement ben alors je
pense qu'il faut les taxer absolument et
les riches attention c'est pas non plus
tous les riches et surtout d'autre part
il faut faire en sorte d'aujourd'hui
interdire certaines choses qui menacent
notre destin collectif et ça c'est
pardon c'est pas quelque chose c'est pas
une un rêve communiste c'est que
simplement on arrive à un stade où on
peut plus fonctionner au 21e siècle avec
des règles qui marchent très bien au 20e
siècle ça veut pas dire ces règles-là
sont mauvaises ça veut juste dire
qu'elles sont plus adaptées aux enjeux
qu'on a aujourd'hui ce qui est très
intéressant dans le livre aussi c'est
que vous dites que l'Europe a vraiment
une épingle du jeu attirer et que face à
la Chine face aux États-Unis qui sont
évidemment des très gros pollueurs être
vertueux c'est aussi être gagnant
pourquoi parce que on a une question
alors non seulement on peut faire des
choses en France quand on vous dit que
la France les industries vertes c'est
pas un gros mot bien sûr que non on va
avoir besoin d'industrie très
probablement la question écologique ce
n'est pas retournée dans des grottes
donc il nous faudra des industries il
nous faudra des chaînes de production y
compris stratégique en terme sanitaire
en termes industriel pur en terme
chimique en Europe et donc il faut
pouvoir utiliser l'Union européenne et
les différents outils qu'on a mais il
faut faire très attention à ne pas avoir
de dogmes et en particulier sur le
libre-échange sur le libéralisme il faut
pouvoir tout réexaminer au prisme des
enjeux dont on sait qu'aujourd'hui en
2023 c'est eux qui comptent et donc ça
c'est l'environnement le climat la
justice sociale et tout ce qui va avec
elle va vite va
falcoillettes c'est passionnant en tout
cas de vous écouter je vous invite à
découvrir faire écologie ensemble on
peut picorer dans plein de chapitres ça
parle aussi beaucoup des des entreprises
tout n'est pas perdu vous n'êtes pas des
croissante mais vous voulez bouger un
peu les lignes du capitalisme on va
garder ça on peut dire ça de manière
comme ça absolument merci beaucoup Léa
Falco on va continuer cette émission
avec nos affranchis vous allez voir leur
partie pré vous faire réagir on les
accueille tout de suite
Carole Barjon de Love séditorialiste à
lobs et Pierre-Henri tavoyau du collège
de philosophie bienvenue les amis pardon
pour le retard mais voilà l'actualité
est très très dense et donc difficile de
faire de tenir les temps on commence
avec Bourbon Express comme chaque soir
l'histoire de Joël assemblée nous est
racontée ce soir par Elsa mondain Gava
bonsoir Elsa bonsoir l'histoire c'est
plutôt une question le président de la
République pourra-t-il annoncer le vote
d'une loi pour les armées le 14 juillet
prochain le chrono est enclenché je vous
le rappelle le 14 juillet c'est dans 8
jours je vous parle ce soir donc de la
LPM la loi de programmation militaire
elle définit le budget des armées entre
2024 et 2030 le gouvernement parle d'un
effort inédit 413 milliards d'euros pour
transformer nos armées et le président
de la République il avait bien
l'intention de promulguer sa loi avant
la fête nationale ça s'avère plus
compliqué que prévu la commission mixte
paritaire vous savez cette réunion entre
des députés et des sénateurs pour
trouver un accord mais elle était prévue
ce matin elle est décalée à lundi alors
moi j'avais suivi ce texte à l'Assemblée
largement adopter aussi au Sénat
qu'est-ce qui se passe pourquoi ça
coince oui on le rappelle regardez à
l'Assemblée c'était au mois de juin
accord très large 48 voix pour 87 contre
et 53 abstentions la majorité la droite
le rassemblement national ont voté pour
les socialistes les écologistes se sont
abstenus au Sénat ça passait également
très largement 314 voix pour 17 contre
oui mais les deux versions du texte
adopté sont sensiblement différentes
regardez c'est ce que l'on appelle les
marges de la LPM c'est à dire les
efforts années après année les sénateurs
de droites ont voulu accélérer le rythme
des dépenses pour investir plus d'argent
dès les premières années c'est sur ce
point que les négociations se
concentrent même s'il y a d'autres
divergences à régler ce qu'il faut
comprendre Myriam c'est que évidemment
en amont de cette commission mixte
paritaire il y a beaucoup de
négociations des discussions les
téléphones chauffent et vont continuer à
le faire tout le week-end l'objectif
c'est vraiment de rapprocher au maximum
les positions et des autres pour aboutir
même si sur les questions de défense on
n'arrive pas à se mettre d'accord c'est
c'est compliqué c'est donc la droite qui
bloque qui profite de la situation
politique pour faire monter les enchères
j'imagine alors c'est surtout les
sénateurs de droite qu'ils se montrent
particulièrement intrans intransigeant
pardon selon plusieurs acteurs du
dossier il profite pas forcément de la
situation politique actuelle mais ils
ont des comptes à régler avec le
ministère des armées à l'Assemblée une
fois n'est pas coutume les débats se
sont très bien passés au Sénat ça a été
un peu plus rugueux les sénateurs de
droite n'ont pas apprécié certaines
déclarations du ministre Lecornu et puis
il y a aussi un autre paramètre quand on
touche au budget il y a Bercy qui
s'emmêle ça rentre dans la boucle ça
fait aussi que les négociations sont un
petit peu plus lentes résultat ce sera
lundi la CMP à 10h30 on prévient d'ores
et déjà qu'elle pourrait durer certaines
heures même si et bien les présents ont
confiance de trouver un accord merci
beaucoup Elsa va suivre ça sur les
réseaux LCP.fr vous saurez tout de ce
vote ou pas sur la LPM la loi de
programmation militaire Carole il y
avait cette idée de former les élèves à
la transition écologique qui était dans
les tuyaux vous trouvez qu'avec la
situation actuelle c'est pas forcément
important d'actualité
en tout cas ça semble dater cette
proposition sans dater d'y à un siècle
puisque tellement les événements ont
changé l'atmosphère dans le pays mais il
faut se souvenir qu'il y a deux semaines
seulement Elisabeth borne avait
effectivement annoncé que les collégiens
et aussi les lycéens mais l'école
surtout elle est bénéficier d'un
enseignement sur la transition
écologique afin de pouvoir obtenir dès
la fin de l'année 2024 une certification
des savoirs verts bonne initiative
malgré tout non alors dans l'absolu
absolument oui oui tout à fait mais les
modalités de ce nouvel enseignement ne
sont pas clairement définies on a cru
comprendre que le temps consacré à cette
formation serait en partie pris sur les
heures d'enseignement traditionnels et
si les enseignements fondamentaux
devaient empathir là ce serait une moins
bonne idée
certes au niveau du collège
l'apprentissage du français est supposé
à qui sauf que ça n'est pas le cas dans
la réalité je rappelle que 20%
des élèves ne maîtrisent pas la langue
française à l'entrée en 6e c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que papel Ndiaye avait
comment annoncé des renforcements des
cours de français en 6e
la maîtrise de la langue française est
absolument cruciale pas uniquement pour
devenir agrégé de lettres mais
simplement pour bien vivre en société on
le sait mais on l'oublie trop souvent
donc faut le répéter savoir s'exprimer
c'est la condition sinequanone pour
communiquer avec les autres et donc pour
vivre en harmonie alors côté et vous
voyez une relation de causalité avec la
situation violente d'aujourd'hui oui
parce que
souvent
ces jeunes qui sont cantonnés dans des
quartiers défavorisés parfois issus de
l'immigration maîtrise mal le français
et on a enfin entendu des spécialistes
de la politique de la ville évoquait
aussi le problème des difficultés d'un
grand nombre de jeunes à manier la
langue française en fait ça c'est simple
lorsqu'on ne sait pas s'exprimer
correctement
lorsqu'on n'arrive pas à clairement ses
idées ou ses sentiments on peut
facilement éprouver un sentiment
d'infériorité en fait face à la personne
qui elle manie et développe son
argumentation avec aisance et ça ça peut
entraîner souvent une forme
d'agressivité voire de la violence il
essaie donc tant que certains en
prennent conscience dans ces conditions
et si la priorité de l'exécutif et bien
de s'attaquer aux causes profondes qui
explique en partie les violences des
jeunes des banlieues on se dit que
l'enseignement des savoirs verts sera
reste la priorité moins urgent pour les
savoir-vers je croyais que vous parliez
les savoirs fondamentaux j'ai pas le
temps de vous faire réagir mais on faut
pas abandonner ce combat là en deux
secondes non mais il faut surtout former
les plus âgés parce que la fenêtre
d'opportunité fait que ce sera pas ma
génération qui pourra agir merci
ce soir vous présidez le collège des
philosophies on a beaucoup parlé de
cette crise de l'autorité et des
solutions pour la résoudre qu'est-ce que
l'autorité vous y revenir sur cette
notion en philosophie oui c'est un
moment assez intéressant parce qu'on n'a
jamais autant parlé de l'autorité depuis
qu'elle est en crise et la crise est
multifactor dans les écoles avec les
enfants rois à l'école dans la
discipline dans les familles avec les
enfants rares dans l'école disciplines
la politique enfin voilà on la voit
partout mais la définir c'est une autre
perd de manche alors comment vous faites
pour la définir faut repartir rapidement
en deux minutes c'est d'abord l'autorité
c'est pas le pouvoir pour une simple
raison c'est qu'il y a de l'autorité
sans pouvoir et du pouvoir sans autorité
le pouvoir sans autorité c'est le petit
chef on l'a tous rencontré donc inutile
de faire un portrait
l'autorité sans pouvoir c'est le vieux
sage qu'on va consulter on dit souvent
l'autorité c'est plus qu'un conseil
moins qu'un ordre l'autorité c'est pas
non plus l'argumentation rationnelle
parce que justement il y a un argument
d'autorité l'argument d'autorité on
l'argumente pas c'est à clos la
discussion donc pour la définir
l'autorité il faut pour une fois faire
référence à l'étymologie ça vient du
latin a au Guéret qui signifie augmenter
pour dire prendre une image d'actualité
avec le Tour de France l'autorité c'est
du dopage c'est du dopage comment grâce
à une substance mystérieuse on booste on
augmente un pouvoir ou un argument pour
qu'il pèse plus qui va le plus c'est
quoi cette substance miraculeuse si on
fait l'inventaire des grandes solutions
de l'humanité à cette substance il y en
a eu trois pour l'essentiel pour aller
très vite d'abord le passé le passé les
grands ancêtres c'est-à-dire ceux qui
nous autorisent c'est pour ça que les
rois sont en général les rejetons des
rois anciens parce que on considère que
ça vient d'avant donc c'est mieux
deuxième solution le cosmos la nature
c'est l'idée que ce qu'on appelle le
charisme c'est ça que l'autorité c'est
celui qui colle avec la beauté de la
nature qui qui colle avec l'ordre
naturel l'harmonie puis troisième
solution bien sûr le divin c'est le
choix de Dieu tout autorité vient de
Dieu c'est dit saint Paul alors ces
trois formes d'autorité pour aller à
très vite sont entrés en crise non pas
en mai 68 mais à la Renaissance à l'âge
classique bien avant c'est-à-dire l'idée
où effectivement le passé devenait
suspecte la nature on savait plus trop
ce que c'était c'est qu'avec Galilée
Copernic etc et puis le divin le divin
qui était censé faire la paix fait la
guerre c'est les guerres religion donc
on se dit il faut trouver autre chose et
c'est ça le problème d'une certaine
façon c'est autorité c'est une
gigantesque crise depuis la Renaissance
alors ça veut dire que la modernité nous
condamne la crise de l'autorité oui il
faut s'y résoudre mais absolument voilà
mais on peut essayer aussi de
reconstruire cette autorité mais de
nouvelles formes il y a une image qui
permet de comprendre très vite ce que ça
veut dire c'est les aventures du baron
de Münchausen vous souvenez ce baron
légendaire germanique à qui il arrive
des histoires incroyable un jour avec
son cheval il tombe dans un dans un lac
et il sait pas comment s'en sortir puis
il a une idée géniale il se prend par
les cheveux ils se sont lui-même du lac
voilà ce truc est totalement absurde ça
a un nom ça s'appelle la démocratie
comment un peuple se donne des lois et y
obéit voilà le mystère et donc ça donne
une formule de cette spécificité de
l'autorité démocratique qui c'est pas
une autorité qui tombe du ciel c'est pas
une autorité qu'on attend Ba qui qu'on
nous voit dans la nature c'est une
autorité très exigeante qui consiste sur
ressources propres à trouver les
ressources justement pour s'autoriser il
y a une formule qui la résume
la bonne autorité de l'âge démocratique
c'est celle qui fait grandir à la fois
celui qui l'exerce et celui qui s'y
soumet c'est une autorité de
responsabilité et non de domination
c'est une belle formule maintenant il
faut trouver les ressources pour
l'appliquer ça c'est une autre
permanence merci passionnant c'est ça
qu'il faudrait aussi avec l'écologie
aussi je sais pas si une question
d'autorité pour l'instant plutôt que de
la démocratie
adhérer des deux côtés certainement
merci beaucoup Léa Falco merci à vous
les affranchis faire écologie ensemble
c'est à dire aux éditions Rue de
l'échiquier pourquoi la guerre des
générations n'aura pas lieu Merci à VOUS
Elsa je vous dis à demain même lieu même
heure restez avec nous pour votre soirée
documentaire qui commence avec
Jean-Pierre Gratien
[Musique]